AND NOW, BACK TO "HANNITY."
♪ ♪
>> HE MADE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS A YEAR.
UKRAINE TOOK CARE OF HIM.
HOW ABOUT CHINA?
HE WALKED OUT WITH 1.5 BILLIONS
TO MANAGE AND NEVER DID IT
BEFORE.
HE DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
OIL AND GAS.
HE WAS MAKING A FORTUNE.
SO WHERE IS HUNTER?
WHERE THE HILL ARE YOU, HUNTER?
I SORT OF HOPE IT IS JOE BECAUSE
HE WILL HEAR WHERE IS HUNTER
EVERY SINGLE DEBATE NINE TIMES.
>> Sean: THAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT LAST NIGHT ASKING
QUESTIONS TO MAINSTREAM MEDIA
MOB SHOULD BE ASKING.
NEVER WILL.
INSTEAD, DEMOCRATIC COMPETITORS
LIKE ELIZABETH WARREN, THEY ARE
GETTING CUSHY PIECES LIKE THIS
FOCUSED ON HER SKIN CARE
ROUTINE.
ANYBODY WANT TO KNOW ABOUT MINE?
MEANWHILE OVER THERE CONSPIRACY
TV, ROSWELL RACHEL MADDOW, 51
CONSPIRACY DNC CHANNEL, THEY ARE
TALKING AND AND LUKE RESEMBLANCE
BETWEEN BERNIE SANDERS AND LARRY
DAVID.
WE HAVE THE TAPE.
>> I AM HERE WITH ENTHUSIASMS OF
DAVID, NO, WAIT.
CURB YOUR ENTHUSIASM'S DAVID BUT
HERE WE ARE TOGETHER.
IF YOU BECOME PRESIDENT, YOU
HAVE TO BE FLYING BACK AND FORTH
JUST TO PLAY HIM.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
IT WILL NOT BE EASY FOR ME.
IT WILL BE GREAT FOR THE
COUNTRY.
BUT TERRIBLE FOR ME.
>> A GOOD JOB OF FOUR YEARS OF
COMPLAINING.
>> THEY ARE NOT RELATED AT ALL.
>> Sean: DO YOU THINK TRUMP
LOOK AT THAT KIND OF COVERAGE?
NO.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SARAH
SANDERS, MICHAEL, THE PRESIDENT
OF G.O.P. CHAIRMAN
REINCE PRIEBUS.
YOU HAVE TO GET BACK IN THE
GAME.
I TOLD THIS TO MARK MEADOWS.
WE NEED YOU BACK IN THE GAME.
I'M APPOINTING YOU SOMETHING BUT
I DON'T KNOW WHAT.
LOOK, YOU WATCH WHAT THEY ARE
DOING TO THE PRESIDENT.
NOW WE WILL HAVE THE SCHIFF
SHOW, SHAM SHOW COME IMPEACHMENT
SHOW, EXPEDITIOUSLY WILL END
NEXT WEEK, SARAH.
BUT THIS HAS BEEN EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
WE HAVE OUR MONTAGE THAT WE RUN
ALL THE TIME COME IMPEACHMENT
TWO DAYS AFTER ELECTED TO COME
IMPEACHMENT THROUGH
2017-2018-2019 BUT THEY DID NOT
GET ANYTHING FROM MUELLER.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SPEAK OUT
298 DAYS.
HOW DOES THIS PLAY OUT?
>> LOOK MY THINK IT PLAYS OUT
EXACTLY HOW WE THOUGHT IT WOULD
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
WE KNOW IT HAS BEEN A HUGE WASTE
OF TIME COME A HUGE WASTE OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND FRANKLY IT
HAS NOT PLAYED WELL FOR
DEMOCRATS.
WE SELDOM PUSH EVERY SINGLE DAY,
TELLING US HOW URGENT IT WAS TO
GET IMPEACHMENT DONE.
NOW, ALL OF A SUDDEN WE HAVE ALL
THE TIME IN THE WORLD TO SIT
BACK AND WAIT WHILE NANCY PELOSI
GETS MORE CONTROL MORE AND MORE
FAR LEFT WING OF HER PARTY AND
REFUSES TO SEND THE PAPERS TO
THE SENATE.
IT'S BEEN A SHAM FROM DAY ONE.
IT WILL BE WIPED AWAY IN THE
SENATE.
AND I THINK IT WILL BE A GREAT
DAY TO WATCH THE PRESIDENT GET
FULLY VINDICATED IN THE SENATE
AND THEN GET TO STAND IN FRONT
OF NANCY PELOSI AND ALL OF HER
CRAZY COLLEAGUES AS HE DELIVERS
A BEAUTIFUL AND AMAZING STATE OF
THE UNION AND TALKS ABOUT ALL
THE SUCCESSES OF HIS LAST THREE
YEARS AS PRESIDENT.
I THINK IT WILL BE A GREAT DAY.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, LET'S JUST
FOR A SECOND, LET'S LOOK 298
DAYS DOWN THE ROAD,
REINCE PRIEBUS.
AND I'VE GOT TO BE HONEST.
I WANT EVERYBODY IN THIS COUNTRY
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS AT STAKE
HERE.
THIS IS AMERICA LITERALLY ON THE
BRINK.
THE AMERICA'S FREEDOM,
$94 TRILLION AND 10-YEAR NEW
GREEN DEAL, $52 TRILLION
MEDICARE FOR ALL DEAL, WE CAN
AFFORD ANY OF THIS.
BUT AND I ALWAYS WANT TO PLAY
LIKE YOU ARE BEHIND A TOUCHDOWN,
NO TIMEOUTS, DOWN BY SIX, AND
YOU NEED THE TOUCHDOWN AND THE
EXTRA POINT, 2 MINUTES, DURING
THE TWO MINUTE DRILL.
THAT IS HOW I WANT YOU TO LOOK
AT THE SELECTION PERIODS BUT
HERE IS MY QUESTION, IMAGINE
THAT WE GET THESE WORDS, WE CAN
NOW PROJECT DONALD J. TRUMP
ELECTED THE 45TH PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
THEY ARE GOING TO LOSE THEIR
MINDS COME ALL OF THEM THE MOB.
>> BUT LOOK AT THIS WEEK.
THE WEEK STARTED ON A NICE EDGE
WITH IRAN.
IT TURNS OUT THE PRESIDENT MADE
THE RIGHT CALL.
IT TURNS OUT IRAN RETREATED.
HE HAD A SOLID JOBS REPORT
TODAY.
AND THE KEY MIDDLE CLASS WAGE
GROWTH UP 3% TO 5%.
THE SAME THING HAPPENED IN 2016,
SEAN.
I REMEMBER DAYS ON THE PLANE AND
I'M SURE SARAH DOES TOO, THE
PRESIDENT OPENED UP
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND NOT
JUST FIND ONE BAD STORY ON THE
PAGE BUT EVERY DAY, EVERY SINGLE
STORY ON THE FRONT PAGE WAS BAD.
EVERYONE SAID YOU CANNOT WIN.
WASTING YOUR TIME, WASTING YOUR
MONEY AT THE RNC.
AND OBVIOUSLY ELECTION NIGHT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WINS THE
PRESIDENCY I'M SHOCKED THE
WORLD.
SO BACK TO THE HUNTER/BIDEN
ISSUE THOUGH, I THINK THE
REPUBLICANS MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER GETTING VERY BOLD IT
COMES HURTING EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE OVER JOHN BOLTON AND
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE OVER
MICK MULVANEY.
: HUNTER BIDEN AND FIND OUT WHAT
THE TRUTH IS.
BECAUSE THE CENTER OF THE
DEMOCRATS CASE IS THAT, WAS IT
REASONABLE FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
ASK ABOUT BIDEN?
IF THAT IS THE CENTER OF THEIR
CASE, BRING IN BIDEN AND FIND
OUT AND EXERT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE OVER THE REST.
>> Sean: I WANT ALL OF THAT TO
HAPPEN BUT WITH THE HOUSE
PRESENT THEIR WEAK CASE.
THE SENATE LISTENS TO THEIR
WEIGHT CASE.
SO THAT AS THEIR SOLE
RESPONSIBILITY OF IMPEACHMENT,
TELLS WHY THEY IMPEACHED HIM AND
THEN CALL THE ROLL.
GET THIS GONE, THEN INVESTIGATE
MR. QUID PRO QUO JOE, YOU ARE
NOT GETTING THE $1 BILLION IN
LESS YOU FIRE THE GUY
INVESTIGATING MY ZERO EXPERIENCE
ON BEING PAID MILLIONS.
THAT NEEDS TO BE GET INTO THE
BOTTOM OF THE PIER THAT IS THE
VERY THING THEY OUGHT TO BE
UPSET ABOUT, RIGHT?
>> IT IS TIME TO MAKE THEM
NERVOUS ABOUT THE GAMES THAT
THEY ARE PLAYING TODAY WITH THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
AND I THINK HUNTER BIDEN WILL BE
A BIG ISSUE.
I DO THINK WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL
NOT TO PLAY ALL OF IT TOO EARLY
WHERE IT GETS OLD POTENTIALLY IN
THE GENERAL ELECTION BUT HUNTER
BIDEN, THERE SHOULD BE A
STRATEGY BEHIND IT.
>> Sean: LAST WORD, WHAT DO
YOU THINK AND DO YOU AGREE WITH
ME, SARAH, SHALL BE CALLED THE
ROLL, GET THIS DONE?
BUT THEN I THINK THEY SHOULD
INVESTIGATE HUNTER AND ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER AND QUID PRO
QUO.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I SAY WE GET THIS IMPEACHMENT
SHAM OVER WITH AND OUT OF THE
WAY.
LET'S LOOK INTO THE BIDENS.
I THINK THERE IS SO MUCH
INFORMATION THERE.
WHAT JOE BIDEN SPENT HALF A
CENTURY IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
SWAMP PIER AT THE LAST THING WE
NEED AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
COME IN AND DRAINED IT IS HAVE H
COME IN AND DRAINED IT IS HAVE E
BIDENS COME BACK AND FILL IT UP
AGAIN.